[Musique]
depuis trois mois il gère la crise
sanitaire de vin et derrière les caméras
depuis trois mois il voit les chiffres
du québec empirer le québec qui affiche
d'ailleurs la triste troisième place du
palmarès des pires pays de la planète
françois legault estime que les lacunes
des centres pour personnes âgées était
trop grande pour éviter le pire
il ne croit pas qu'un autre plan
auraient pu être mises en oeuvre
pas en tout cas la partir de la mi mars
il était trop tard dit-il
mais on verra il y aura une commission
d' enquête technique et des changements
dans la structure dès 6 h et celle d il
reconnaît s'être retrouvé bien seul au
sommet j'ai rencontré monsieur legault
là où il donne ses points de presse à
montréal sur le go bonjour bonjour nous
voit on est sur la scène où vous vous
tenez ce point de presse à montréal
et vous avez encore dit aujourd'hui à
quel point on avait perdu une partie de
cette bataille-là passé la catastrophe
les seiches sld à quel moment vous êtes
dit on est en train vraiment de perdre
le contrôle est ce que c'est et rennes
qui a été le point tournant un petit peu
avant presque dès le début parce qu'on
avait quand même à chaque jour des
rapports sur les décès et puis on ne
commence à avoir des 17 est très
concentré d'abord à montréal dans
certains ces achats soldés en dans
lanaudière lavaltrie ensuite en estrie
mais c'était tout dans des ses achats
soldés
les premiers dessins et quand monsieur
docteur arruda le 9 mars y réunir vous
une réunion au sommet avec vous ils vous
convainc de fermer le québec
à ce moment le 9 mars à peu près 9 mars
il ya divers fois commencent à prendre
des mesures donc arrêter de se donner la
main être prudent
dans les regroupements mais s'applique
quand même je dirais une semaine avant
le docteur who do viennent à nous dit là
il faudrait peut-être fermer entreprises
il était même prête à prendre deux trois
jours pour le faire mais moi tout de
suite j'ai dit mais là on parle de vies
humaines
même son impôt la liste des services
essentiels c'est aujourd'hui que ça se
passe
donc c'est à peu près comme nous
semaines plus tard parce que votre côté
pragmatique dont vous parlez souvent au
début où vous êtes il faut pas passez
moi l'expression faut pas nier this way
absolument c'est ce qu'en politique les
gens aux communications aime bien tous
soient préparés qu'on ait un questions
réponses
quels commerces vont être fermés quels
sont ceux qui seront pas fermés il y
aurait voulu prendre quelques jours mais
moi tout de suite le jeu dit non c'est
aujourd'hui que ça se parle c'est
peut-être un peu seul de mon camp quand
j'ai pris cette décision là j'étais seul
les gens vous disais prenons quelques
jours mais pourquoi vous vouliez parce
que je voyais que
je lisais un peu ce qui se passe
ailleurs dans le monde
je voyais qu'il ya des décès puis on se
disait là il faut absolument éviter la
propagation de ce virus lors puis la
seule façon c'est que les gens restent
chez eux mais vous avez vous-même
d'ailleurs très tôt dans la crise le 11
mars
vous avez dit la pire chose qui pourrait
arriver c'est que le virus se propage
dans les centres à ce moment là le 11
mars
ils étaient où le plat sacha qui
manquait du monde parce qu'on savait
qu'il manque est membre ils étaient où
le plat pour protéger nos vues bon à
l'époque suite au début on ne dit toutes
les personnes qui ont des symptômes ça
soit des visiteurs ou des employés
doivent rester chez eux
mais l'on s'est rendu compte après
quelques semaines que même les personnes
qui avait pas de symptômes pouvait
transmettre le virus que l'on s'est
rendu complice est trop tard dans
l'épreuve les premières semaines les
visiteurs les employés ont répandu le
virus dans des centaines de chcd oui
mais vous aviez pas autour du 9 10 11 12
13 mars
quelqu'un que j'ai la main en réunion
autour de vous en disant on n'est pas
équipé dans les sachets celle des on
sait qui manque du monde donc en voyons
des gens des hôpitaux en voyons des gens
je sais pas même un plan d'urgence pour
faire en sorte qu'à pauthe
on regardait ce qui s'est passé en
italie en france à new york
partout il y avait le même problème
c'est qu'ils manquaient de lit donc les
gens qui étaient atteints de l'aco vie
depuis qu'ils avaient des conséquences
graves incluant les personnes dans les
centres de soins de longue durée
ben on les amène à l'hôpital mais il
fallait libérer des lits on a libéré
sept mille lits donc on était prêts dans
les hôpitaux même apprendre ce qui
venait dé chcd donc c'était seule la
priorité parce qu'ailleurs on
choisissait qui est traité qui est pas
traiter qui elle doit un ventilateur qui
a pas de ventilateur
donc nous on voulait être certain
d'accueillir tout le monde dans nos
hôpitaux
mais avec le recul est ce que ray pas
fin du
transféré beaucoup plus de ses résidents
là dans les hôpitaux mieux les protéger
avoir du personnel des hôpitaux qui
était là alors qu'ils étaient pas là
dans les centres pour vieux mais en même
temps les centres pour les personnes
âgées sont quand le ch et celle des rpa
et ressources intermédiaires
il y avait deux cent vingt mille
personnes on peut pas prendre 200 av
vingt mille personnes que les mettre
dans nos 5000 lits qu'on avait libéré
dans urgences des hôpitaux
donc c'était pas possible de le faire
mais au fur et à mesure qui en avait qui
étaient malades ont les transférer mais
là ça s'est propagé à une vitesse
incroyable en quelques semaines on avait
des milliers de résidents qu'ils étaient
infectés donc à ce moment si vous ne
voyez pas ce que vous disent oui
naissent des mines et serait de faire
différemment pour sauver des vies dans
les seychelles
si on avait eu parce qu'il nous manquait
dix mille employés d'un ch celle des
puits la moitié des employés à temps
partiel travailler dans 2 3 4 ch à celle
des donc ce qui est arrivé c'est quand
il y avait un employé qui est infecté il
ya les infecter des gens dans 3 4 ch à
celle des donc c'est sûr que si l'on
tenté de se préparer
si on avait eu juste des employés à
temps plein on aurait pu aussi le je
voyais beaucoup de personnes qui
disaient faut absolument que ce soit pas
les mêmes personnes dans les zones
chaudes que dans les zones froides mais
on faisait oui mais on n'a pas de
personnel c'est là j'ai commencé à faire
appel à tous les volontaires pour nous
recruter dix mille personnes qui en a
pas de formation mais au moins son nu
s'occuper des résidents quand vous êtes
aperçu que non seulement il mourrait
parce que c'est une chose pour le
beaucoup dit dans nos émissions les
statuts les personnes âgées
d'abord malheureusement c'est comme ça
mais quand vous êtes aperçu qu'en plus
ils mourraient dans certains codes
déshydraté sa personne pour leur part
les esseulés dans les gens ne
s'imaginent la des corridors vide
imaginez vous votre mère la demande
comme on pêche quand j'aurai des fonds
ça apportera les de chercher on la
ressent ça ça descend c'est l'horreur
mais l'heure est arrivée deux choses il
est arrivé d'abord il manquait déjà dix
mille personnes s'apprêtaient l'umq ne
lui un autre dix mille soit qui est
infecté les employés étaient infectées
soit qu'il a peur d'être infectés le don
qui était rendu qui nous a manqué vingt
mille puis là on était dans une
situation où en plus on serait pas trop
si on devait accepter des projets dans
non parce que moi je parlais avec des
directeurs généraux de centres qui me
disait monsieur legault arrêter la
visite là parce que les visiteurs
incluant les projets dans vienne
infecter les résidents donc fermé des
visites mail en même temps fermer la
porte à un prochain qui viennent nourrir
son père ou sa mère
c'est cruel donc un malin dès qu'on a
pensé que c'était possible de réouvrir
on aurait ouvert puis on a commencé à
leur donner des masses badie bella même
si vous avez des seins tombent
venez vous occuper avec new hope avec
les volontaires qu'on a mis en place des
personnes aînées mais c'est ce que vous
avez vous même qualifié de gênant pour
le québec
totalement moi j'ai ma mère de 91 ans
qui est encore à la maison
imaginez vous ce matin ma main cela
serait dans un centre comme ça et puis
quand on n'avait même pas de personnel
pour les nourrir leur donner à boire
parce que hein on a fait l'erreur tout
le monde ensemble qui manquait dix mille
personnes puis en plus en a ajouté un
autre dix mille employés qui ont quitté
soit parce qu'ils étaient malades y
avait pas de trappe et lakovic les
inhumant quête personnelle pour ça aussi
on a beaucoup parlé des directives qui
était pas suivi il ya des directeurs
généraux qui ont décidé malgré la
directive de quand même laissé des
employés qui avaient des symptômes de
quand même laisser entrer des visiteurs
parce qu'ils se disaient c'est mieux le
zoo que pas personne pour nourrir ou
pour faire boire
ok donc pas de pas de regrets en dix ans
j'aurais dû le 9 10 11 12 mars sphère
sociale
oui je peux
c'est on savait qu'ils manquaient de
monde dans les chu celle d'e.on
augmenter les budgets de façon
importante
quand je suis arrivé il ya un an et demi
mais ces budgets l'ont jamais été
dépensés parce que les poses sont
affichés puis ont été comblés et on se
disait on va négocier des augmentations
de salaires au mois de mars 2020 ou
renouvellement de la convention
collective
mais moi je le regret que j'ai c'est
qu'on avait dû augmenter ça l'à beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus vite comme on le fait
que les primes commission technique
qu'est ce que c'est ça que vous
privilégiez une commission technique un
peu comme après les inondations la com
sur nikolai une commission qui prendront
pas 4 c'est ça moi on essaie de trouver
une formule où on va aller au fond des
choses mais que ça prendre proto d'un
pour qu'on puisse corriger la situation
bon déjà on sait qu'il ya un problème de
personnel donc les dix mille personnes
qui commencent cette semaine leurs
formations vont indisponible 15
septembre donc ça va aider l'autre chose
qu'il faut faire
je parvenais sur le projet de loi 61 le
mais il faut rénover nos ch celle d il
faut bâtir des nouveaux ch se dit qu'on
va appeler des maisons des aînés cheney
encore aujourd'hui on a des sièges celle
d où il ya deux trois quatre patients
dans même chambre où il ya des petites
cette chambre où il ya pas de place pour
faire des zones chaudes seul il faut
fois gepsa presse pour l'automne sommes
nous prêts à la deuxième on va être
prête le personnel on va être prêt que
le personnel parce que les dix mille
employés qu'on tenterait de former fonds
être prêt le 15 septembre les masques à
janvier mars georges tron
z'auriez des commandes en janvier le
sait c'est faux parce que on ne jamais
manquer demain ce mois chaque matin je
regardais masque n95 masques
chirurgicaux blues bien on aux premiers
jo on ne jamais manquer on y faisait
mais n'avait pas
même pas une semaine mais quand trois
ministres y en avait un plan b pour au
collége en les mettant dans des coffres
mais on s'est fait voler des masques on
s'est fait voler des masques écoutez
vous l'avez vu à grandeur de la planète
tout le monde cherche des masques savez
comme x 10 le prix des mailles en a
assez pour lol pour l'eau il y en a
assez pour l'automne il ya aucun
problème
montréal si le ciel deuxième wagon
souhaite pas qu'elle soit forte mais
mettons qu'elle est plus forte la
deuxième vague est ce que ça va être
mieux organisé il n'y avait pas de
capitaine
je résume le ca entrer dans les six des
dix maisonneuve rosemont avait trop de
malades la kfw demande et vous l'envoyez
des patients au chum
je maudis non ya pas de capitaine à eau
pour dire oui vous faites ça c'est à
désorganiser
moi je dirais que c'est plus en bloc y
avait pas de capitaine parce que à
québec
l'équipe du ministère forcé les hôpitaux
à transférer des employés vers les ch à
celle des staffs facile pour les 6 ou
lis sur ce qu'ils avaient sous leur
responsabilité des chs ldc tu as moins
facile le convainque les chu les centres
hospitaliers universitaires qui ont pas
de ces achats celle des de prendre des
infirmières des préposés que les envoyer
dans les ch à celle des mais quand je
dis car un problème en beau c'est que
suite à certaines réformes qui ont eu
lieu dans les dernières années plusieurs
ch celle des n'avait pas de directeur
général ou de directrice générale
le patron ou la patronne s'occupait de
3,4 à sa gauche à très bientôt comme à
damier tôt avant l'autre vous souriez
non mais on va faire ça l'écouté on est
là dre absolut caisse avant la pause
il faut faire une pause la fermeture du
québec il avait du talent a rejeté seul
mais je croyais que c'était la chose à
faire est ce que par ailleurs avec le
recul de permettre les walmart de
seulement d'ouvrir son show votre on
comprend en même temps ma sur mer rue
commerçante
monsieur qui vend des jouets pour
enfants lui est en train de mourir
avec le recul ce qui aurait pas fallu y
aller peut-être moins à la hache facile
à dire après vous allez me dire j'avais
non même même après ou avant garde et
vous avez un one man qui vendent à
nourriture mais qui vend d'autres choses
aussi la jetée pop mettre des policiers
mots d'un walmart pour s'assurer qu'ils
vendent juste la nourriture
donc il fallait que tous les québécois
accès aux plus de nourriture possible
incluant dans les grandes surfaces qui
vendent d'autre chose que de la
nourriture donc facile d'arriver puis
disais mais pourquoi vous avez pas
justes ouvertes certains départements
comment on fait ça en pratique
puis moi je voulais pas non plus limité
les québécois encore plus que ce qu'ils
voyaient et pour l'automne
il y aura plus de fermeture même si les
codes mondiaux on en sera plus de 20 une
fermeture à 7 et chaleur pour le québec
ben c'est ce que dit le docteur who d'or
je pense que il ya des mesures
alternatives qu'on a mis en place les
gens ou le voile os se tiennent plus à
deux mètres portent des masques
s'ils sont pas capables d'état 2 m donc
ça rappelons-nous mois de mars
y a personne qui avait ça en tête de
rester à deux maintiens l'opt et des
masques sur le gore faut faire une pause
mais pente par les masques pourquoi vous
le rendez pas obligatoire c'est rendu
que nos spécialistes ne nous le dit
chaque jour pourquoi vous le rendez pour
janvier un peu ce que je parlais tantôt
par rapport aux world mc voulez-vous que
j'engage les policiers pour aller jouer
à police pour s'assurer tout le monde un
masque pixi la personne qui a pas
d'argent pour acheter un mass air soit
une pénalité parce que sinon son emploi
dans votre esprit c'est par ses
disciples d'applications vous c'est vous
qui décidez d'être écoutés quand on le
cadre qui s'est pas aussi depuis trois
mois c'est au québec dans les soixante
états et provinces où les gens le plus
suivi les consignes donc moi je fais
confiance aux québécois hockey après la
pause on parlait de l'éducation de la
rentrée beaucoup de gens se posent la
question ce qu'on vend devrait rentrer
entre haute et de raciste
beaucoup de gens me disent une seule go
que moi je voudrais pas du tout ça soit
plus qu un conte sciemment il ya des
préjugés enfouis sûrs comme deux groupes
de pensée un groupe de pensée qui dit ça
s'appelle systémique pilote qui dit non
non non ça s'appelle positive est géré
par barclays d'une chicane on va diviser
les québécois au moment il faut les
rassembler pour tous ensemble dit il
c'est tolérance zéro
monsieur legault les parents se
demandent est ce qu'il y aura une vraie
rentrée là on a aujourd'hui délier un
peu donné de l'espace de marge de
manoeuvre aux enfants dans les écoles
est ce que dans votre esprit et c'est ce
que vous souhaitez une vraie rentrée
physique pour tout le monde absolument
écoutez moi j'étais 3-1 l'éducation pour
moi c'est une priorité personnelle à
aider entre autres le vin 25% des
enfants qui ont des difficultés
d'apprentissage ça pas de bon au sein
qu'ils soient pas allés à l'école dans
certains cas ce montréal pendant six
mois pour ça que j'ai pris le risque
d'ouvrir en région mais j'avais pas la
cas du docteur ou d'europe la santé
publique pour ouvrir les écoles
primaires à montréal j'aurais pu ouvrir
au mois de juin
mais ouvrez pour deux trois semaines
avec tout ce que ça impliquait je pense
ça répond valu la peine
par contre ce qu'on a essayé de proposer
aux syndicats c'est d'avoir des quins
pédagogique cet été pour les 20-25 % des
enfants qui ont des difficultés
d'apprentissage
ça peut marcher c'est d'ici qu'est ce
qui arriva mini speed milieu de
l'éducation
notre collègue martin biron enfin texte
maintient qu'un remaniement dans votre
tête qui se promènent et que lui serait
peut-être un des premiers être déplacés
c'est complètement faux parce que jean
françois robin est un excellent ministre
de l'éducation il fait un très bon
travail quand on aurait ouvert les
écoles primaires région le savez mal
marché on l'aurait su ça s'est bien
passé
on est en négociations avec les
syndicats de l'éducation comme avec la
fiq ou si vous avez vu les publicités de
l'aef horreur on a demandé aux
enseignants cet été d'accepter de
travailler dans des camps pédagogie et
ont pas aimé ça
puis on est en négociations on veut
augmenter de façon importante les
salaires des préposés aux bénéficiaires
on veut donner une meilleure
augmentation aux enseignants mais l'oeil
des syndicaux qui voudraient plus
mais dont vous attribuez et son passage
difficile aux négociations dans le
secteur public essentiel essentiellement
votre confiance pour la prochaine année
largement totalement leur chemin
puis je vais vous dire jean-françois
aussi aurait aimé être capable d'ouvrir
les écoles avant puis là je te content
aujourd'hui doctor who do a annoncé que
pour les enfants de moins de 16 ans au
pouvoir et à un mac ou un mètre et demi
donc en pratique la tous les enfants
dans les écoles primaires secondaires
vont retourner à l'école le premier à
pente
dans une autre vie avant un débat avant
votre élection m'aviez dit maternelle 4
1 c'est ma priorité je serais même prêt
à renoncer à mon siège si j'arrive pas à
le faire
l'avis donné d'autres sujets de
préoccupation depuis mettons mais est ce
que vous y allez selon le plan initial
maternelle 4 ans ou bien vous allez
revoir ce dont tu vois que le plan
initial parce que actuellement janvier
où 20% d'enfants qui ont des difficultés
d'apprentissage
c'est prouvé qu'ils sont commence à
mieux s'occuper des autres dès l'âge de
quatre ans trop dans des maternelles
avec des orthophonistes des autos
pédagogue
on multiplie leurs chances de réussite
donc on n'a pas le droit à la lionel
carmant travail ce agir tôt donc évaluer
puis donner des services même avant 4-1
ensuite la maternelle 4 1
pensez un suivi avec beaucoup plus
d'autos faunesse d'orthopédagogues
racisme oui je vous poserai pas le
moustique
on tourne en rond mais beaucoup de gens
vous disent y en ait beaucoup de gens
vous disent monsieur legault que moi je
me considère pas du tout un être à 6 0
mais ça ce pull que inconsciemment il ya
des préjugés en fuite et ses sols et si
dieu avec le raciste sais pas ah c'est
pas le klu klux klan l'appui les gros
méchants
vous êtes d'accord avec seul instant
suffit là je suis d'accord pour dire que
il ya du racisme au québec puis dans
certains cas c'est dans l'inconscient
mais il faut il faut être prudent de
porter un jugement sur l'ensemble des
québécois la majorité des québécois sont
pas racistes mais on a un problème de
racisme au québec puis ya comme deux
groupes de pensée un groupe de pensée
qui dit ça s'apaise systémique pilote
qui dit non non non ça s'appelle peau
systémique est géré par barclays d'une
chicane on va diviser les québécois au
moment il faut les rassembler pour tous
ensemble d'îles c'est tolérance zéro le
minimiser pas le problème en disant que
c'est pas systémiques
c'est ce genre ça dépend de la
définition de systémique
si je prends la définition de systémique
de d'il ya un système au québec un
système chez les policiers dans la
fonction publique un système qu'on lit
minorités visibles mouche pas d'accord
avec cela il ya des personnes racistes
chez les policiers les employeurs vous
leur donnez combien de temps pour
accoucher de quoi ce qu'indiquent les
lions 3 mois en fait d'ici l'automne
pour arriver que des actions puis moi je
veux que ces actions là comment cette
prise avant noël
donc moi je pense qu on y peut à
l'époque de faire des commissions qui
vont durer pendant des années on est à
l'étape d'âge est de poser des gestes
pour plus qui est de racisme au québec
rêver quand le comité de suivi des
recommandations de du
ce rapport au charbon nous la commission
charbonneau vous a dit là vous allez
trop vite avec votre projet de loi 61
votre chien est à mort car c'est devenu
cc radioactifs là quand on dit
commission charbonneau corruption
collusion québec gteam vous avez su à ce
moment là où j'étais fini je m'imagine
pour le projet de loi hope unis c'est
partie remise parce que bon faut
expliquer d'abord qu'avant même la
pandémie on est en train de préparer un
projet de loi ok parce que les ministres
l'eau surtout transports éducation santé
viennent me voir à chaque semaine le dit
françois riffaud a livré il ya peu près
rien qui va se passer d'ici la fin du
mandat parce que fo qui est un processus
d'expropriation impôts si ce processus
d'évaluation environnementale un
processus de vérification des
soumissions minimum 4 à 7 ans pour faire
un projet taylor il doit un bon livre le
rêve ils ont utilisé une méthode
spéciale clp libéraux sont incohérents
c'est qu'ils ont permis pour leur m une
exception est exactement ce qu'on
propose pour le projet de loi santé a
cité les expropriations facilité
expropriations accélérer les évaluations
environnementales donc les libéraux ont
fait pour l'heure m exactement ce qu'on
demande pour la ligne bleue pour les
maisons des aînés si vous revenez avec
sa l'automne janvier il a pu mais on va
l'expliquer à population que nos
objectifs
c'est pas dur commence à fait de la
corruption comme les libéraux là quand
même
cela vaut ça on parle de béton puis
décolle ps bravo au losc hyves apprend
aussi mais est ce que la crise de vous à
pau sur votre radar fallu mais un point
il faut investir plus dans les
technologies vertes dans les
technologies ces seules la nouvelle
économie de l'environnement de déployer
des milliards aussi ailleurs la clé au
québec pour l'environnement c'est
l'électrification des transports
parce qu'on a beaucoup d'électricité
mais on produit pas de pétrole pour ne
pas l'intention d'en produire donc you à
montréal la ligne bleue gueule tramway
d'un lest à longueur
il ya deux projets de tramway vient
projet de tramway à laval il y en a un
autre à gatineau
c'est ces projets là que je vais avancer
rapidement pour l'environnement puis le
sang ils étaient toutes dans la soirée
en 61 vous êtes demain aux journées on
va te mine et ça c'est obligé la ligne
bleue à montréal et ses rythmes
puisqu'on nous dit non mais si a pas de
projet de loi 61
allez voir les anomalies voir les
personnes qu'ils connaissaient ils vont
vous dire on en a pour quatre ans avec
les expropriations pour la ligne bleue
selon les processus actuels avaient mal
grand piano pour quatre ans avant
commence à construire le prolongement de
la ligne bleue
est ce que c'est ça qu'on veut - ce pas
ce que je vais vous avez mal expliqué
que tous les groupes qui sont sortis par
écouter l'opposition s'oppose
et puis les jeunes robe les bars où les
grecs t il nécessaire s il nous restait
quelques semaines de session
on va se reprendre à l'automne on va
mieux l'expliquer sur le vo qu'est ce
que cette crise là vous a appris sur le
rôle du premier ministre kenney qui sait
pouvoir
on a beau être bien entouré d'avoir des
milices d'avoir une équipe
il reste tellement l'année il faut
prendre des décisions et puis on est un
peu seul puisque des chanceux d'avoir
mon épouse pour me supporter parce que
sept jours par semaine à prendre des
décisions pendant la crise
ça devient lourd mais
ça fait partie de la job j'étais s'est
senti seul mais à certains moments
oui quand j'ai décidé de réouvrir les
écoles puis j'avais à peu près tout le
monde est dans l'opposition ce mot bord
qu'ils aident les enfants peu pour lui
ouvrir des écoles en région
je me sens un petit puzzle jeu le grand
resort parler bonetti vous allez prendre
quelques jours quelques années vous
laisse avec mon corps et je vais essayer
d'aller en estrie par charles voit
passer quelques jours de vacances avec
mon épouse nous inviter monsieur des
rubriques gérer le voir aussi
marseillais d'aller au boss elle renvoie
pas ce cas merci monsieur labeaume merci
monsieur roy